hi
i'm bill turkell i'm a professor of
history at the university of western
ontario
in canada today i'm going to talk about
my experiences using mathematica
for text and image mining in my own
research
i want to say a little bit about the
differences between humanities research
and research in science and technology
humanities research is conducted under
very different conditions than the stem
disciplines
science technology engineering
mathematics
i want to explain why mathematica is a
wonderful programming environment
for humanists or for people working in
the humanities and i'm going to talk
about teaching the techniques that i use
to students who have very little or no
background
in technical material scholarship in the
humanities
including history differs from science
and endanger and
engineering along a number of dimensions
first
there's a focus on close reading and
interpretation
of sources these include things like
texts images
artifacts and media second
there's an expectation that humanities
researchers will often work in work
alone
in fact sometimes they always work alone
third humanists are trained in ways that
rarely include
much background in math or computation
and finally humanists typically receive
much less in the way of research funding
which changes the way that they do
projects in groups of larger than one or
two people
if humanities researchers are going to
use powerful computational tools
in their own research tailored to their
own research
typically they have to develop those
tools on their own
here i'm going to start by describing a
number of examples of small research
projects
where the coding was either all done by
one person
namely me or all done by a few people
including me
the first project that i'll mention was
one of the largest that i've been
involved with
over a number of years research teams
that i was on relating to this project
included between two people and about 12
people at a time
in the humanities when humanists think
of a large project this is typically the
kind of thing that they're thinking of
no more than say a dozen people the old
bailey
online is a fully searchable edition of
all of the criminal trials that were
held at london's central criminal court
between 1674 and 1913
it is quote the largest body of texts
detailing the lives of non-elite people
ever published
i didn't have anything to do with
creating this resource that was done by
other teams of researchers but between
2010
and 2013 i wrote about 70 odd
mathematica notebooks to mine the text
of the old bailey
online now the fact that mathematica
notebooks support what knuth called
literate programming
makes them an excellent way to
communicate technical ideas to
colleagues
who have less background in technical
materials obviously they're specialists
in the
subject matter the figure that you see
in this slide
shows the length of a criminal trial in
words on the y-axis
plotted against the date of the trial on
the x-axis
the murders in this archive are depicted
with a red draw
red dot and all of the other trials are
depicted with a
lighter more translucent gray dot and in
fact
most of the trials in the archive the
majority of the trials in this archive
are actually thefts
now one of the things that's interesting
about this graph if you just kind of
squint at it
is you'll notice that the trial length
starts to bifurcate in the 1800s
with some trials being less than about
100 words in length and
some of them more than a couple of
hundred words in length but they're
relatively few in between so there's a
split in trial length
now this pattern of behavior persists
over
more than 50 years and until we plotted
the
data in this form no one had actually
noticed that it was there or had
observed that it was there and it
reflects a number of factors
but among other things it reflects the
rise of plea bargaining in the 19th
century
and the rise of the guilty plea
let me turn to a project that's just
getting started
and this is one that's more typical of
my research collaborations
i'm working with one other person amy
bell and she's an expert on mid 20th
century british cultural history she's
an expert on the subject matter
the time in the place and i'm handling
the programming and
the methods more generally for our
project
our practice as we work together has
kind of like the agile
development technique of pair
programming so we can sit down and share
now virtually of course but we can sit
down and share
a screen with a mathematica notebook and
we can use computational techniques to
explore our sources
we can document our thinking in the
notebook we can write down our questions
our interpretations
ideas as we work so in other words
mathematica notebooks a shared notebook
allows us to have
a computationally augmented conversation
about sources and interpretation
the subject of our research in this case
is the mass
observation project in 1937 the mass
observation
organization began recruiting hundreds
of volunteers to write diaries and to
answer questionnaires
and they also paid investigators to do
things like go into public situations
and just write down people's
conversations and descriptions of their
behaviors
and the goal of the project was to
better understand the lives of ordinary
britons
and this project resulted in an
extensive archive of the daily life and
culture of mid-20th century britain
for this work as i say we're just
getting started we're working with a
method called distributional concept
analysis which was developed by peter
dybala and his colleagues
and whereas many text analysis methods
uh rely on n-gram windows that are
centered on a word of interest
the dca method is interesting because it
relies on small n-gram windows that are
positioned
some distance before and after the word
of interest
something like dca is is relatively easy
to implement i think it took
probably a couple of days to get the
code in working order so that we could
begin to start exploring
this text with this particular technique
another project that i worked on for
many years that involved text and image
mining
was conducted with a former student of
mine
he and i applied a number of techniques
to the subject of
stage magic in the late 19th and early
early 20th century
and what we were trying to do is we're
trying to develop a kind of an
experimental approach to history
so we use techniques like desktop
fabrication and physical computing
unfortunately this was before
mathematica had a good support for 3d
printers and microcontrollers so a lot
of that work wasn't done in mathematica
but we also did a lot of text and image
mining
we had a fairly large collection of
periodicals books
and in a number of cases entire runs of
magic magazines
and part of the work involved
automatically and extracting
images from those page images and then
identifying the things in them
people apparatus card tricks and so on
the picture here from that project shows
some of the
now problematic orientalist costumes
that magicians of the time
preferred to wear
here's another example let me just start
this running
here's another example of images from
that same work
there's a collection at the university
of manitoba that contains
seance photography from the early 20th
century
and some of these images are actually
stereo stop stereoscopic pairs
with a few lines of code it's possible
to create a wobble image
that alternates left and right frames
rapidly
and in this case i actually put the code
in the presentation notebook
but i'm happy to provide code for other
examples
if you contact me
another collaborative project that i've
been working on for a number of years
also involves text and image mining for
this project i started by using
mathematica to write crawlers
to compile an archive of millions of
pages of text from the open web
and the kind of thing that i was
collecting were texts that relate to the
histories of electronics
of computation and of scientific
instrumentation
one focus of this work has been
developing tools that can understand
circuit diagrams
these images show the automated labeling
of components in a circuit image
so this image was extracted
automatically from the surrounding text
and then we then go through and use
machine vision techniques and that kind
of thing to automatically
label and identify components underneath
the
labeled schematic you can see the
network that shows
the the ways that those components are
connected to one another
and our ultimate aim in this work is to
develop a system
that can identify meaningful assemblies
of components meaning meaningful
design idioms if you will they occur in
schematics
above the level of individual components
so when we think about
being able to do semantic search for the
history of electronics
we want to be able to search for design
idioms things like
a wheat stone bridge for example and not
for just to be able to search for a
particular resistor particular capacitor
which isn't nearly as useful
as a final example i'll mention another
project in the history of engineering
that we just started
my collaborator here is a retired
professor of civil engineering
we're creating a large database of
historical bridge images with a lot of
metadata
we have about four thousand images right
now but the number is growing daily
and we're combining these records in our
database with linked open data
by mathematica's new support for sparkle
queries
and we're developing machine vision
system to go along with it the idea is
to be able to create a system that can
look at historical bridge images and can
extract
features that are of interest in the
history of civil engineering
now as a historian of electronics i'm
finding this work
to be quite fascinating in part because
my colleague continually shows me
how bridges themselves have
the design principles and the design and
the computations embedded in them in a
way that can actually be seen in the
artifact
i'm used to working with sources or with
materials
where much of the work is focused on
technologies that try to make invisible
things visible
things like oscilloscopes and schematic
drawings help us understand electronics
in the case of bridge images more of it
is there to be seen in the image itself
and we hope to be able to
use machine vision and image processing
techniques to really bring out that
aspect of these particular sources
so that's a sketch of some of the
projects where i've used mathematica
but let me step back to provide a wider
perspective
a doctoral student in the humanities
typically undergoes what are called
comprehensive exams or qualifying exams
where they're expected to demonstrate
their mastery
of hundreds of books and using
mathematica i've been working on a
workflows
that can scale up that process by at
least say an order of magnitude
so it's an expectation in humanities
that using traditional techniques
people would routinely work with
literature on the order of hundreds of
books
but the question becomes if we augment
those people computationally
if we make them cyborg humanists as it
were
how can they quickly establish
familiarity with a literature that's on
the order of say five to ten thousand
books
or the equivalent and i'm going to turn
to some of the techniques that i use and
teach
toward that end
any source that contains links to other
sources can be crawled
the canonical example of course is web
crawling and in fact i love to show
colleagues who know how to program
the one line web crawler from the
mathematica documentation just to give
them a sense of some of the things that
the
language can do with its very high level
commands
now in this case what i'm showing is a
crawl of
very limited crawl of the worldcat
identities api
this is a two-hop crawl of related
records around the mid 20th century
author
walter lipman the identity site gives
access to about 20 million records
metadata for persons institutions
fictional characters and things like
that that are mentioned in public's
pub published sources or that published
sources are about
now of course mathematica also provides
a very rich collection of tools for
categorizing
nodes or characterizing nodes vertices
networks so we can use all of those
tools on anything that we crawl
and we can also resolve entities like
walter lipman himself
to enter to entities in mathematica's
entity framework
and we can resolve them to entities in
sources of linked open data
like wikidata and this provides us a
tremendous access to still more
computable knowledge
when we have texts which we've gathered
by crawling or other means
we can make connections between those
texts and we can make things in those
texts findable
by way of indexing in this slide i'm
showing an example of a method called
rake rapid automatic keyword extraction
and i'm using it on the wikipedia
article for information overload
now rake is an excellent way to extract
phrasal keywords particularly
in shorter texts like abstracts and
summaries
and if we combine it with more
traditional methods some of which
mathematica
is now implementing like tf idf
we have a good way of assessing the
relevance of a particular text
to a particular query and we also have a
good way of measuring the similarity
between pairs of texts if we combine
this
with entity recognition especially in
the form of mathematica's pretty amazing
text
contents command and its relatives we
can link
keywords that we find that we extract
either through tf idf or through rake
to entities we can also use keywords
as a very useful form for discovery
so i find since i often work with large
collections of sources that have been
kind of curated by me
intentionally i find i'll often have a
question a research question
and the answer is actually in my sources
and the keywords lead me to the location
of of what i'm looking for i've often
already collected the answer to
questions that i'm just coming up with
mathematica now as of more recent
versions has a large and growing
collection of methods
to do unsupervised clustering of texts
which can be very useful
but sometimes also interesting to be
able to code your own and again this is
typically just the work of a day or an
afternoon to get
up and running this particular slide
shows a compression clustering algorithm
that was developed by rudy c labrezy and
paul vitany it's based on
kolmogorov complexity but in a form that
can be implemented
on a computer and it is used
here on the biographies of various
people who are important in early
canadian history and it shows us
relationships between those people if
you uh know these people or these town
you'll
this time you'll recognize some of these
people in the relationships
now i often use quick clustering
algorithms like this one
for discovery while i'm writing so i can
write a paragraph about something
and then i can use a clustering
algorithm to cluster the paragraph that
i've just written
with all of my sources and the sources
that best match that paragraph are
typically the ones that i want to cite
if i haven't cited them already for this
kind of application
if you're clustering your own writing
with your source base
to look for more ideas more linkages
that you hadn't perhaps thought of or
more references that are useful for you
it makes sense to burst your documents
into smaller units and again it's the
matter of a line or two of code in
mathematica to burst
a document into paragraphs or pages or
250 or 500 word text blocks
or whatever is useful for your
application
one fast technique for mining things
like terminology or for getting a sense
of the semantic
characteristics of your text is the
random indexing method of magnus sulgren
and his colleagues
now like a number of useful methods this
one creates vectors of coefference
events that occur
in a context window around a particular
word
it's based on random vectors which means
that the dimensionality of the space
never increases
so this is very fast and it scales well
to really large text collections
and again it's easy enough to implement
in a page or two of code
the example here shows left and right
contexts of two words in alice in
wonderland
said and replied and what it shows us is
that
alice lewis carroll preferred to use
the phrase said alice instead of alice
said
but he preferred to write alice replied
instead of replied alice so by looking
at the
left context of replied and the right
context of said
we can see that those terms are the ones
that are most likely to be found
in front of or behind those particular
verbs now random indexing
can also be used to find words that
pattern together
so we find in alice in wonderland that
in the places where we find the word
alice
we would also find in similar
environments we also find words like
king
caterpillar pigeon and so on sulgran and
his colleagues
show how to use random indexing to
measure the semantic density of words
they show how to use this technique to
study semantic evolution over time and
how to monitor
ongoing discourse for anomalies
many problems in text mining boil down
to the ability to approximate the
similarity between two documents of
whatever sizes
without entailing the costs of actually
doing all pairwise comparisons in a
large text collection so if you have
you know millions of pages you have very
many more of course possible pairwise
comparisons
you don't want to have to compute those
all in order to do useful measurements
ben schmidt's method of stable random
projection is very useful here
he worked with the hottie trust digital
library which has about 13.6 million
books
that are available to researchers not as
text but in the form of a bag of words
representation
and using a sketching algorithm called
stable random projection
then shows that it's possible to store
distinctive
information for each book each of those
13.6 million books
in about two and a half kilobytes each
so this is
about a 50-fold reduction in storage
space from the bag of words
representation which of course itself is
a reduction in storage space from the
actual text
ben plotted these he did a dimension
reduction technique where he plotted
all of these books in a two-dimensional
space and he shows that they
cluster naturally on a wide number on a
number of different scales
so at the largest scale text cluster by
language
within a natural language the next level
of clustering is by subject
and then by genre and then by date or
style
and then by authorship and finally by
individual
works and i've extracted a small portion
of one of the figures from his paper
here to show that kind of
zooming in effect where you can zoom in
to a particular genre like poetry to a
particular time like the 1800s
to a particular author like sir walter
scott then to individual works and we
see that clustering repeated at every
level
now i find this technique to be really
incredible
schmidt doesn't have access to the full
text of these 13 million
sum books for each book he only has a
list of words and the frequency of each
word
but using the sketching algorithm which
is fast and easy to compute again it's
just a few pages of mathematica code
it creates very small representations
he's able to encode
a space or he's able to create a space
of sketches that encodes
similarities and differences of more
than 13 million books
and these similarities and differences
are meaningful to us
as humanists as humans at multiple
scales
and yet the technique doesn't require
the work of human classification at all
mathematica makes it possible for one
person to plausibly develop
sophisticated computational analytics at
the same time as making use of
traditional
research methods like close reading and
scholarship permanent scholarship of all
kinds
in my teaching i introduced many of
these methods to undergraduate and
graduate students in the humanities and
social sciences
and i use an open source open content
and open access textbook
that i developed and now it has about a
hundred
some odd screencasts to go with it
unlike
science or engineering classes most of
the students
have little or no physical little or no
technical background
once in a graduate class at i think was
the first day of class and i only i
learned this lesson quickly but once in
a graduate class i used the word integer
on the first day of class and one of the
students said
i hate math words and all of the other
students agreed with them
so i had to kind of rethink how i was
going to teach these students this kind
of material
on the plus side i found most of my
students have no
preconceived notions about how difficult
or how easy something should be
so i can introduce concepts and code
based on
the usefulness the utility rather than
based on the difficulty and that's one
of the things that mathematica
makes very easy
in conclusion let me say a few words
about why mathematica
is a perfect choice for programming
humanists the fact that many of the
commands are very high level
makes it possible for a single
programmer to accomplish a lot
quickly with a few lines of code and
this makes it less intimidating for
students too
when teaching i focus on the skills of
reading code i encourage students to
copy and modify
expressions to see how they work
mathematica's phenomenal
documentation is a great resource for
this the fact that the language
is holistic and inclusive also supports
humanistic
inquiry which tends to prefer
interpretations to be holistic
and this is buttressed in the language
by extensive access to computable
knowledge
both in the form of the built-in entity
framework and the new modes
of access to linked open data
notebooks allow for literate programming
typically
even when i'm working by myself i'm
writing as much prose in a notebook as i
am
code when i'm working on something and
the
literacy of the notebooks facilitates
communication with students and with
colleagues
the notebook also provides a
computationally enhanced view
into a world of sources which is how
many humanists are used to thinking of
their work
the notebook becomes a space that has
similar properties to libraries
archives museums and other cultural
heritage institutions that humanists
often work in
and notebooks support a kind of a pair
programming
approach to interaction between
colleagues whatever their
level of skill i've been programming at
this point for more than 40 years
daily often and one of the things that i
like most about working in mathematica
is that i'm still learning learning new
things about the language and i'm
learning new things with the language
every single day
thank you
i'm here
happy to answer questions if anybody has
anyone welcome
before i started teaching with zoom i
probably would have found it
disconcerting to be
confronted with a bunch of uh
blank rectangles with people's names on
them but now this is kind of my
this is my life these days
bob knock bar here i used some of the
your
code from your first edition uh when i
was doing some
text analysis of novels trying to pull
out character relationships it helped me
get into the text um but i ended up
having to
write a lot of rules to to parse the
text to find the conversations because
that's what i was interested in
just finding the conversations was a
real challenge
um and then finding you know and then
determining
who was the the speaker um
oftentimes you could find that because
it was for example like
alice said you also had a deal which she
said or he said
um or dialogues that went back and forth
without
uh speakers being mentioned
explicitly do you know of any tools
that are available that would make that
sort
of uh mining easier
to process the text i have
not i mean i have not looked at it i
haven't looked specifically at that
you're certainly right that things like
embedded
um embedded dialogue could be a bit of a
trick and because
the sort of better the writing the less
he said she said he said she said
is in there the harder the kind of the
harder it is to understand in some sense
one um one
thing that occurs to me is that
uh that
character dialogue probably has
different properties
than that than the surrounding text just
in terms of things like patterns of
verbs
and uh sort of pronoun use especially
like i
i i s if the book is written in the
second person
a first person singular pronoun would be
kind of a good clue that you're probably
looking at a dialogue rich
section of the page i mean with the with
with mathematica's new neural net
capabilities it's so easy now to train
learners to do things like that like to
look at a page and and you can even just
kind of highlight portions of it and say
this is an example of
narration this is an example of dialogue
and you know you could train it up on
a tiny amount of labeled pages and see
how well it does on the unlabeled ones
that's a good idea about pronouns and
stuff i was relying mostly on
syntax uh quotations yeah but
uh even with modern texts where the
author writes with the text processor
and the the publisher then produces it
you will still find errors yep and
you know one dropped quotation
messes up everything downstream yeah
yeah and and trying to go in and clean
that up uh
so that the data extraction would
continue to work was a real challenge
i do find that the that mathematica's
new high level text commands
like text words and text sentences and
text contents
yeah those are those are pretty sweet
for for doing things
that even a couple of versions ago would
have been quite hard to accomplish so it
might be worth checking into some of
those
and see if you can find ways to improve
because there's also there's also things
like the um kind of sentiment detection
type things or the facebook
classifiers and there's all kinds of fun
stuff in there
yes i was using sentence structure to
find the speakers
nice in particular yeah yeah and i've
talked with jerome
uh uh laurador who does a lot of the nlp
neural network about some of these
things oh cool
well don't let me hog the conversation
somebody else speak up
we have until 10 past four central time
uh
so if we have any more questions now is
the time to do it
i'm also happy to kind of meet with
people or do a assume
during or after the conference if people
have other things they want to chat
about
well for those of us who've been
involved with mathematica for
three decades
in your area of expertise
um the question arises
and i've done some work in
journalism with this stuff and uh and
editing with this stuff that it's been
extraordinarily powerful as you say the
high level commands are
very powerful but um
connecting with people at sort of a
an academic level or a local level i'm
here in sacramento
is virtually impossible you can your
network is made up
primarily back into missions i assume
[Music]
i can't seem to find um
[Music]
a broader scope of folks who i think
would be interested in this stuff um
outside of the university level i don't
know how to
uh there's incredible power here
but it's uh how to make it meaningful in
a world where
people are clearly focused on other
matters at the moment
um is
is difficult perhaps making it pertinent
to
the current conversations would be
pertinent will be
of value but again i don't know how to
uh i don't know how to do it there's no
linkedin for this type of problem
yeah i see that amy uh suggested in the
chat that meetups are a great way to
connect with people who are interested
in this kind of thing
i was also going to say that um i've
been kind of
i've drawn a lot of inspiration and
ideas from people who call themselves
computational journalists or data
journalists
they as far as i know they don't
necessarily work in mathematica a lot of
them work in
r or other languages like that but but
if you can
if you can bond over the the task
then perhaps um the the language is then
something that can be negotiated
yeah i thought a lot of i found a number
of people uh
were working in r um
and uh which is fine because
obviously uh mathematician can wrap
around our
exactly uh
but i find it a small community and they
don't maybe it's if it's too modern
you know it's not maybe 100 years behind
before it's time or something anyhow our
artifacts from the future as steven was
saying it has various uh
various talks really
uh well but it would in turn do you find
an
audience outside of your your student
body and
i mean uh or a way of
of of expanding uh the value this stuff
has value the question is
where's the audience uh
whether the 17 folks in your seminar who
you know where are they yeah my my uh
strategy is usually just to put stuff up
as
as kind of open access and and hope that
people will find a path to it if it's
the kind of thing that they're
interested in
so where do you post that oh uh sorry i
put stuff
up on my own website i put it up on
github and i
post it to places like the wolfram
forums because i know that at least the
people who are looking there are
interested in mathematica or or
the wolfram language or are already
using it
have you had any interaction with
historical societies the various
uh um i would
say there there are there are a number
of people who call themselves digital
historians but that that's a fairly sm
or digital humanists more generally but
that's a fairly small
still proportion of um of the people
who in in the in my field per se
i see that amy has her hand up and i
would say that she is also a digital
humanist so maybe she has a
a different perspective on this
hi hello hey amy
hey um thank you that was really
fascinating and
thank you for speaking up for the
humanities
i'm wondering if the working in the way
that you do
it it has enabled you to um
build any significant bridges to connect
with um people in other disciplines
where you might not have been able to do
that
or um or maybe you've been able to help
students see
those connections between disciplines
just that
we work in such separate silos
so often it's true yeah actually the
i do teach the digital research methods
as a
course and this i mean for the past
couple years many of the students have
been drawn from
kind of across the university and that
was true also when i was teaching the
intro digital humanities programming
course i used mathematica for that for a
couple years and the students were
coming from all over the place
i find that i i certainly enjoy inter
like interdisciplinary work with people
in other fields and disciplines
in terms of like usually what gets in
the way
at the university level is often the
kind of
reward structures that are and the
disciplinary
boundaries which are often policed by
people who say they're interested in
interdisciplinary work but actually
go out of their way to penalize it in
various ways but
that's just i mean i'm not going to let
it get me down that's for sure
but as i say happy to i'm happy to
continue the conversation
either in uh either in kind of
during the conference through little
zoom chats or or
afterwards just send me an email or
contact me somehow
thank you very much thank you my
pleasure
thank you thank you very much thank you
guys thank you very much